HYPERSENSITIVE SOUL.
HE'S ON A BEDBUG COMING IS MORE
LIKE A BABY BEDBUG.
IT WAS REACTION, FIRST ACTION
SENIOR ADVISOR, SEAN SPICER, AND
THE AUTHOR OF THE BOOK STILL
WINNING, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
CHARLIE HURT.
YOU KNOW, YOU ARE BOTH LAUGHING.
SHAUN, WHAT ARE YOU DOING GOING
ON THAT STUPID DANCE SHOW, WHAT
ARE YOU THINKING?
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?
I MEAN I ADMIRE THE COURAGE.
SPEAK LIME AND HAVE SOME FUN FOR
GOODNESS' SAKES.
I NEED YOUR VOTE.
LET'S GET OUT THERE AND SHOW
THESE PEOPLE.
LET'S SHOW THEM WEEKEND --
I WOULD HAVE SOME FUN AND IT'S
ABOUT TIME I ENJOYED MYSELF AND
HAVE A SHOW THAT I CAN ENCOURAGE
MY KIDS TO WATCH.
I GIVE YOU CREDIT.
LISTEN, YOU'VE TAKEN A LOT OF.
I TAKE IT EVERY DAY.
YOU'RE IN THE WRONG BUSINESS.
IF YOU CAN'T TAKE A LITTLE BABY
BEDBUG TAB, YOU DON'T BELONG
OFFERING YOUR COMMENTARY.
PEOPLE VOTE, YOU KNOW, YOU OF
THESE WORRIERS THAT ARE NEGATIVE
IN THERE BUT BASEMENT FIRING OFF
ONE SHOT AFTER ANOTHER.
TAKE IT.
>> I THINK IF THAT'S THE WORST
THING THAT HE HAS BEEN CALLED,
MY GOODNESS, TAKE A LOOK AT MY
TWITTER FEED ANY DAY.
I WELCOME THAT HE CALLS HIM A
BEDBUG.
OTHER PEOPLE WILL SHARE IT WITH
ME BUT I'LL TELL YOU, THE THING
THAT SO INTERESTING ABOUT THIS
IS THESE GUYS CAN'T TAKE A
PUNCH.
I AGREE WITH BRETT IN THE
STANDPOINT THAT I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD BE USING THAT KIND OF
LANGUAGE BUT IT'S AMAZING WHEN
FOLKS ON THE LEFT END OF THOSE
NEVER TRUMPERS THAT CLAIM TO BE
FROM THE RIGHT GO OUT AND
DEMONIZE EVERYONE WHO SUPPORTS
THIS PRESIDENT TO LOOK, THE
MATTER THE FACT IS THE
PRESIDENT GOT GOT HER INTO SIX
ELECTORAL VOTES.
INSTEAD OF DEMONIZING US IN SO
TRYING TO OSTRACIZE US, THEY
MIGHT WANT TO LEARN FROM US
BECAUSE AS YOU POINT OUT, THERE
IS A LOT OF HARDWORKING MEN AND
WOMEN OUT THERE THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S MESSAGE RESONATED
WITH AND IT'S ABOUT TIME WE
STARTED LISTENING TO THESE
PEOPLE MORE INSTEAD OF TRYING TO
PUSH THEM FURTHER AND FURTHER
AWAY.
>> Sean: ONE OF THE THINGS I
ADMIRE MOST ABOUT THE PRESIDENT,
HE GETS HIT HARDER THAN ANYBODY
I'VE EVER SEEN IN POLITICS.
ANY FIGHTS BACK.
AND HE DOESN'T STOP.
AND THEY CAN HANDLE IT.
>> YOU HE NEVER GIVES UP, IT'S
AMAZING.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE GUY GET
THE ENERGY TO DO THAT BUT
WATCHING THE CLIPS THAT YOU
SHOWED, SOUNDED LIKE I WAS
WATCHING CNN.
ON THE INCOME OF THESE HAVE LOST
THEIR MIND.
THEY HAVE BECOME COMPLETELY
MENTALLY UNHINGED AND I THINK
FOR THEM THE IDEA OF THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ONE IN 2016 IS
ABSOLUTELY --
THEY STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN THEIR
BRAINS AROUND THAT AND ON    ONT
BRAINS AROUND THAT AND ON    ONE
FOURTH AT ONE HALF YEARS LATER
HE IS STILL WINNING ON A DAILY
BASIS, HE IS RACKING UP HUGE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND ALL OF THE
REGULAR AND NORMAL AMERICA IS
FINDING THINGS TO COMPLEMENT
ABOUT HIM AND THESE ARE PEOPLE
THAT CANNOT STAND HIM.
>> Sean: AIRED, DISPLAYABLE,
SMELLY WALMART PEOPLE, SAYING TO
GOD, BUNS, BIBLES, RELIGION.
I WANT TO HANG OUT WITH THOSE
PEOPLE.
I'M NEVER GOING TO WASHINGTON.
IT'S NOW IN MY CONTRACT THAT IT
DON'T HAVE TO GO.